de la fumée noire s'élève à nouveau dans
Kiev il est environ 8 heures ce
journaliste de la BBC fait un point sur
la guerre en Ukraine lorsque tout à coup
une détonation retentit juste derrière
lui
la scène est filmée sous un autre angle
par des riverains ce conducteur se
trouvait à quelques dizaines de mètres
seulement lorsque le missile a explosé
plusieurs détonations ont été entendues
confirmées par le maire de la ville
d'après les premières informations un
missile aurait touché des
infrastructures situées proche du palais
présidentiel
on dénombre plusieurs morts et des
blessés parmi les habitants ceux qui
devaient être un lundi ordinaire à
rapidement tourné au cauchemar
juste à côté de voiture en feu des
secouristes prennent en charge les
premières victimes
un peu plus loin la profondeur de ce
cratère témoigne de la puissance de la
déflagration en plus de Kiev plusieurs
autres grandes villes du pays ont été
visées
ils essaient de nous détruire et de nous
rayer de la planète il tue nous
concitoyens qui dormaient à zaporigia il
tue tous ceux qui allaient au travail
admis pro et à Kiev
la capitale ukrainienne vivait dans un
calme relatif depuis plusieurs mois
après le retrait des troupes russes en
avril dernier un calme apparent qui a
volé en éclat ce matin
voilà sachez que nous reviendrons